in the past 24 hours i have become
an nft
mogul
yes
i'm a crypto king
i am i'm a tech wizard i don't know what
any of these things are really but i
i heard about the non-funchable tokens
that's an nft and that is as far as i
can tell a digital representation
of
an image or a tweet or some kind of
digital property so i thought it would
be funny
to dip my toes in the waters of nfts and
crypto i
minted
an nft this digital token of my tweet
announcing
five years ago my blank book
reasons to vote for democrats so if
you're it's kind of hard to follow i
created a digital kind of nothing
of it of a tweet which is kind of
nothing about a book which doesn't have
any words in it it's nothing
and i auctioned this off
and a really discerning art collector
paid
1492 for it the 1492 you might recall is
the year that columbus sailed the ocean
blue it's great
uh elisa sweet little elisa did not want
me to take this money she thought it was
wrong because she
bizarrely thought that my tweet wasn't
worth anything
it's insane i did i instead of wanting
to donate it to charity i wanted to
transfer it to my local cigar shop we're
still debating this if you feel free to
weigh in in the comments section
but it did raise this question to me are
the nfts worthless
i i don't think they're necessarily
worthless we're all joking about it now
oh what it's nothing it's just a what i
can't even hold what does it mean well
first of all
if you've got a painting an original
painting and you've got a an embellished
print
you know a print where it's got kind of
the contours of the paint on it if you
look at the original and the print
very often you can't tell the difference
but there is a difference one is worth a
hundred bucks one is worth
ten thousand dollars
why well because one is the original and
it's just even though they look
identical one is the original okay i
kind of get that analogy
furthermore
i think nfts might not be a total scam
because
they potentially could have value in the
metaverse
walmart just came out with this
dystopian terrifying clip of how they
expect you to go shopping in the
metaverse the metaverse is when you put
on your virtual reality goggles and you
sit in your little pod and we're always
quarantining for the rest of our lives
and you go and you go through a virtual
aisle and you buy pick up the virtual
bottle of wine and the virtual
strawberries and then they just ship it
to you and you just get it at your door
and that's that and there are three
companies that you shop at and you get
everything so in that digital world if
as mark zuckerberg thinks we're going to
be socializing in the digital world we
started it during kovid
during what some have called a great
reset where you you would get drinks
online on zoom you'd catch up with your
family on zoom well what if you did this
in this fully immersive experience if
that happens then having a digital
property like a non-fungible token
would be much more valuable than a than
a physical property if i have a physical
wristwatch if i have a physical handbag
if i have a physical leftist tears
tumbler that ain't worth jack in the
metaverse but if i have the nft then it
is so why do i think this could happen
because it sounds so hellish and hideous
and dystopian
that of course we're gonna do it right
of course our
ruins of a civilization that we're
living in is headed in that direction
and so
i do think there is a slight chance
i hope we can stave off that virtual
reality but just think about how how
much closer the ruling class has pushed
us toward living in a virtual world even
the push for transgenderism
which my friend james pulas at the
claremont institute observes is probably
just uh
dipping your toes in the waters of
transhumanism right this idea that our
bodies don't matter i'm a man but i feel
like a woman so i'm just gonna say that
i'm a woman now the physical world
doesn't matter well if you're in the
metaverse you can you can look like
marilyn monroe you can look like audrey
hepburn even if you're some big fat
hairy dude
that would be
an ideological inducement down that step
this is clearly where the liberal
establishment the ruling class is trying
to take us do we have the hoods but do
we have do we have the
will to live to to to pull out of that i
don't know we're a dying population can
we turn that around i certainly hope so
i'm so glad you liked that clip welcome
to my humble abode welcome to the inner
sanctum
if you want more insight like this if
you want more special glimpses into
what's going on in my mind
in my home then i would strongly
recommend you
ring that bell
subscribe get those notifications head
on over to apple podcast but if i stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you